أمريكا والدول العظمى
دائما ما تصنع لها طرفا ثالثا
في البلدان التي تشكل خطرا عليها،
وقد فعلت ذلك أيضا مع العقيد معمر القذافي
، الذي لم يستطيعوا إخافته،
بل إنه قام بتهديد أمريكا علنا،
وهنا علموا أن سقوطه لن يكون إلا من الداخل
وكما جرت العادة،
لا يسقط القادة العظماء
إلا بخيانة المقربين،،
(القذافي وحفتر وللقصة بقية)
كان خليفة حفتر ضابطا يعمل في خدمة القذافي
لسنين طويلة
، وعندما انقلب القذافي على الملك إدريس
وأمسك بزمام الأمور في السلطة عام ١٩٦٩
، كان خليفة حفتر من ضمن الكوادر الشبابية
من ضباط الجيش، وبعد ذلك أصبح حفتر
يدين بالولاء للعقيد القذافي
ويعمل بتفانٍ في خدمته،
حتى وثق به العقيد ونصبه قائدا لأركان  القوات المسلحة الليبية،
وفي عام ١٩٨٩
وتقديرا لولائه عينه القذافي هذه المرة
كقائد للقوات الليبية التي تقاتل في تشاد
لكن حفتر فشل هذه المرة،
وسقط أسيرا بيد القوات التشادية
إلى جانب ٣٠٠ من جنوده،
عند ذلك وجدت المخابرات الأمريكية فرصتها،
فالعقيد حفتر قد سقط بيد رئيس تشاد حسين حبري
، الذي يعد من أفضل حلفاء أمريكا في المنطقة
، خصوصا أن أمريكا وقفت معه في حربه ضد العقيد القذافي،
عندها ذهب حبري إلى حفتر في سجنه وأخبره بأنهم
سيدعمونه مقابل الوقوف ضد القذافي،
لم يكن إقناع حفتر بتلك الصعوبة،
فقد وافق على الفور،،،،
وخلال تظاهرات وأحداث عام ٢٠١١
سرعان ما انتهز حفتر وضع البلاد وعاد لينضم للمحتجين،
وأصبح واحدا من القادة الرئيسيين للمظاهرات
والهجمات على قوات القذافي وبدعم مباشر من أمريكا،
وعلى الرغم من أن كثيرا من المتظاهرين
قد أبدوا شكوكهم بصدق حفتر لأنه كان عميلا لأمريكا
منذ أسره في تشاد، إلا أن الدعم الذي حظي به حفتر
ساعده كثيرا ورفع من اسمه في ليبيا
ولو بخيانة القذافي نفسه
الذي صنع من حفتر رجلا عسكريا وقائدا لقواته
وها هو حفتر يساعد المحتجين وقوات التحالف
بخيانته للعقيد القذافي،
وكشفه للكثير من الأماكن التي يتواجد فيها العقيد
، وتسريبه للمعلومات السرية لقوات القذافي
، فكان سببا رئيسيا في سقوط العقيد القذافي
،، وفي عام ٢٠١٥ عين مجلس النواب الليبي
حفتر قائدا للقوات المسلحة، لكن حفتر
لم يخن القذافي ليرجع مرة أخرى إلى منصبه،
وإنما ليسيطر على البلاد برمتها،
وبعد ذلك بعام واحد شن حفتر عملية عسكرية
للسيطرة على المنشآت النفطية،
ثم قام بمعاهدة مع رئيس الوزراء فايز السراج
ليعملا سويا لإنهاء الأزمة في البلاد،
لكن حفتر لا يفي بوعوده ولم يستطع الوصول إلى هدفه
على الرغم من الدعم الذي يحظى به من أمريكا،
وظلت البلاد في فوضى وستظل كذلك
طالما يحكمها الخونة،،
صنع القذافي لحفتر مسيرة لم يكن يحلم بها،
لكن لم يحصد القذافي من ذلك إلا الخيانة
والخيانة فقط من تسقط القادة،،،